well there's been an intense exchange of
Rocket fire across the Israel Lebanon
border Hezbollah said rockets and
artillery it fired from Lebanon hidden
Israeli army base in the north footage
shows the scene including extensive
damage to the base the Israeli military
has not yet reported any casualties
Israeli media say the military
intercepted another barrage of drone and
Rocket attacks Z is in Aur in southern
Lebanon with this update
the conflict along the Lebanon Israel
border has been increasing in intensity
yes it is still largely confined to the
Border area a few kilometers on each
side of the Border but there has been an
intensification in the attacks the
Lebanese armed group Hezbollah for
example in recent days has been mounting
on average at least 10 um operations
against Israeli military positions along
the border on Monday it targeted an
Israeli uh position uh heavily Target
Target that Israeli position in the
central sector and uh what is rare is
that footage video of the aftermath of
that strike has emerged it is rare for
the Israeli military to allow such
images to be broadcast of a position uh
largely destroyed that level of
Destruction which some may interpret as
a possible warning that Israel could
intensify its retaliation against the
against Hezbollah it has been carrying
out air strikes artillery shelling
targeting what it says are sources of
fire in Hezbollah positions along the
border but there have been occasional
hits deeper inside Lebanon so Hezbollah
targeting this Israeli position with
four missiles what is known as the Buran
missile that's what Hezbollah calls it
each one could weigh up to up to half a
ton so two tons of explosives targeting
an Israeli position um people are
concerned that this conflict which has
been you know confined to the Border
region could escalate and could spread Z
AL Southern Lebanon